oh you're gonna love storm oh the bounds
up to a million there's over a million
people say they're gonna do this you got
it caught on fire so much the government
had to go but well no it's a it's an
actual Air Force Base do not storm the
base you [ __ ] morons how stupid do
you have to be to rush area51 demand
answers a to sign up for that
B to actually do it but seed actually
think you're gonna get through a
government official military base yeah
they're gonna light you get someone's
definitely in shot in the face yeah I
mean something Bad's gonna happen
the vent I'll storm a 51 y'all get you
should definitely make sure it's I'll
tell you what's gonna show Stormare for
doing t-shirts it goes they can't stop
all this well yeah they can I can you
know how how many you know how it's
called tear gas you [ __ ] dummies and
water hoses enjoy that alright it's so
easy for them to stop again how many
guys cool just just drop tear gas but
how's that conversation go hey God like
you're trying to convince like let's say
it the whole movement you're up their
own thing like hey so we're gonna storm
area 51 cool on my first answer how we
can get in we're just all gonna storm it
no you keep saying that but like how are
we gonna physically get into the
building because it's a government
building and they're gonna come through
area and you have to get a know where
but it's also a common Oh secluded just
a block off all that you know they'll
see you coming a mile away
how about your meter 51 they can't stop
all of us what they can do they
definitely can yeah yeah yeah yeah you
you enjoy getting enjoy the water hoses
and tear gas in your face etc keep
scrolling down that's that's where you
guys gonna run huh oh and you don't
think the government can figure this out
huh
you think the government some right
you oh hey what you think the government
seem like a million they're right we
can't stop them come check things out
back to that hey everyone make sure you
put away the alien so I won't have such
a bad headache you hate your body you
haven't had plain water and over 36 hour
your sleep schedule was non-existent
your baby a meal a day know is that I
don't I thought that
I thought was about area 61 but don't
ever read that again
how crazy is more of a gag it's more of
a gag with the fact that this so many so
many people are signing up for it means
that there's gonna be a certain
percentage that might actually go oh you
know we're gonna show up about a hundred
and twenty out of the million and
they're like what the [ __ ] dude all
right what's the planning like yeah
uh-huh
imagine go that way in the ghost way
yeah flying to [ __ ] Vegas and you
rent a car all right
there's no the 50 where area 51 is in
like where is the closest town he said
Las Vegas but if you're gonna do it
don't tell everybody you gotta catch
them off guard bro everyone knows this
catch them off-guard now it's written
out out that's out that's out dude now
they're gonna know now if a million of
people showed up unannounced that's the
move but now they know you're already up
for him do 83 miles northwest of Las
Vegas it's a military base you're gonna
ain't nobody getting in there click on
that Washington POIs post boys Jesus
guys what happens if they actually show
up
I'm telling about 13 people are gonna
show up god damn it dude I hope if
someone shows up they have a GoPro on
their face I'm so interested how the
government handles it there's block off
roads ah got TV stop your way let's damn
blitz Syrians like yeah let me write the
hell cause what happens you have to
drive their stage credit huge traffic
jam get out and walk see what happens
to say or somewhat let's see them
everything go to fire someone said let's
hashtag let's see them aliens
let's the other thing if she I pray to
God you got I'm actually I support this
gives me hilarious I need to
entertainment but if you do get in
do you really this what's so funny do
you really think that guns gonna leave
the aliens out if they are there yeah
there you go we'll meet here this the
thing we will meet up at area 51 alien
senators attraction and coordinate our
entry so that means no one's thought
about it if we not TRO run number two no
route or run we can move faster than
their bullets if Liz are trying the
truth Naruto is an anime and they're
like notorious for running like this you
always have someone kid in high school
who ran like that like ran from class to
class like [ __ ] this oh they call it
no I need not write out my why they
caught Naruto because it's from that
show Naruto oh we had a different name
for it when I was a girl my niece's
Jamie's that word runs off like that
it's hilarious you can't use that word
anymore no we used to call kids that ran
like that Paul yeah
speaking of the Washington Post Friday
air force they ever spokeswoman they
write just want a response said
officials are aware of the event already
you're [ __ ] when asked how authorities
would respond to the explorers and ur
said she can elaborate on the plants
yeah cuz they're beat the [ __ ] her
she did however issue a warrant to those
issued to try their luck area 51 is an
opening training range for the US Air
Force and we would discourage anyone
from trying to come into the area where
we trained American armed forces the US
air force always stands ready to protect
America and its assets Jesus Christ
I see how the CIA so so the the
government Americans were told for
decades
area 51 didn't exist at all now the
notion was officially debunked in 2013
when the CIA can first confirmed this
existence through documents obtained in
a public records request by George
Washington University which is what I
was saying there is the the in Freedom
of Information Act you have to have a
very specific reason why you are keeping
secret of course the government has
secrets but there there is a lot of
information that you can get I don't go
Virgili government show yeah keeps going
down chin what happens if it if they
were just like if you do come at us
we're just gonna lie either [ __ ] up
yeah come on down our guys need target
practice staff signs that suggests those
who enter could subject a deadly force
dude it's a military base oh yeah wonder
who seemed to be the hottest girl that
runs runs at him that's good tits that's
great do you think it's all white people
neither think it's people who are
obsessed with the idea I think it's just
like I think it's just a cool thing to
talk about and sign up for not sign up
for your community because I may have a
million people I can't even wrap them we
were down to rush area51 creates
merchandise
it's what everybody you you belong to a
community it's cool to be in an online
chat room here's the thing I hope
they're successful Brian what if they
get in there and like that bob lazar
everything said was all true or baba
yaga Bob Lazar might have been working
on drones in their infancy to that the
US government uses because they were
working on drums forever and not to that
magnitude Oh shoo describe oh yeah that
well of course they were no drones the
drones they use now were in we're in
development a long long time ago so
drones have always been something that
the US military was thinking about so
you know it's it's very possible that he
doesn't working on something that was a
was it drone or it was from the dude
lights from the start I hope I support
this I hope they're successful and get
it done and it comes all true and then
you're gonna look like such a dummy
gotta be so it's God be awesome what if
one runs out with an alien like we got
him when you see this that documentary
on the inventor and how they tried to
fool everybody but then what happens is
the pressed suit once you get these
investigative journalists who had just
David they start sniffing around oh they
can make their name onyx but how come
little bit Bob later on he's a little
too crazy like nobody cares the press
like figure it out yeah nobody care
aliens figured oh yeah nobody cares who
are you say cat never know if the
smartest people in the world never
mention it like Stephen Hawking's and
and also who else oh yeah
will Stephen Hawkins isn't saying that
the government has UFOs not saying they
don't exist or that aliens don't exist
but he's saying you know there are a lot
of those people that really follow stuff
like this and they don't seem a little
is it great but it's a lot of the guys
who don't know anything about aerospace
or anything I hope they're right that's
all I'm saying dude now do we have tea
fat K UFO shirts coming yeah we do okay
no we didn't fence we do either yeah
call them infants nope didn't do them as
thing cuz I was very offensive but
something else you interview a folk
deity fat kid shooters who makes those
shoes do jump about those for me or off
tool just keep doing your doing you know
get onto Anna barn get a head Lac what
else you got gin I did they do make it I
hope they make it maybe this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]